hi y'all name's wendell
and i am in fact
a sexual addict
hello thanks for calling mario's pizza
this is carlos speaking
oh wow we would like
a large pie with a pepperoni pineapple
and cheesy crust large pepperoni with
pineapple and cheesy crust
we would also like a
large pie with bacon pineapple
and cheesy crust large bacon pineapple
with cheesy crust okay
is that gonna complete your order sir
you know what let me gauge the room
uh guys are we gonna want another pizza
let me just who's hungry show her hands
let me see them
one two three keep them up four
five six
yup pretty big one two come on guys keep
them up
hugo summer hands food you know what
let's play it safe
let's get another pie pineapple
all right um oh you guys are gonna need
cheesy crust on the third good question
i'll gauge the room hey guys
do we want cheesy crust on the third
okay yeesh
that is a resounding yes for cheesy
crust
on the third claire says you read her
mind
claire huh i like that name it's a good
one
oh also uh my boy andy over here is
saying you have something called
chicken poppers is she cute uh who's
that and what now
claire oh
her body's like a four anyway we would
also
how do you mean
let's just say she's kind of a big girl
that's all good that's all superficial
man i like claire for what's inside
don't even know claire yo but for real
though i feel like i do know claire man
put me on the phone with her
uh you don't need to speak to claire
no i do
you know what i gotta level with you man
i sir
oh oh i'm sorry i i i didn't mean to
get in between you guys no it's quite
all right
twas a while ago before she blinked up
my current girlfriends live body
tan face tan
but anyway claire yeah i hit that
sexually and uh as did my boy hugo
hell even bubba got some of that so just
wanted you to know
used goods to use goods so you wouldn't
care if i asked her out
well let me do it for you hey claire
this guy from the pizza place wants to
date you too poor all right i'll let him
down wait
wait wait wait wait no
tell her no i'm not a rich man
but i'm a good man tell her claire i
believe in destiny
and i believe that we've always known
that our soul mate
was out there the moment that we had
that unspoken connection about the
cheesy crust
i realized that you were always the one
because and i know this sounds corny
but that moment was just like
simple
wow you really do care about claire
[Music]
i do oh my god claire just got shot
what no oh it just came through the
window it was a [ __ ]
in the neck oh claire's down she's dead
she's dead i'm calling the cops she's
dead
crap
well chinese it is i wake up next to
this guy and
as usual i don't even know his name
i'm trying to get dressed quickly and
get out of there before he wakes up but
i can't find my underwear i look
everywhere but i just can't find them
and then it hits me i had left them at
another guy's apartment
earlier that night and that's when i
knew i had a problem
[Applause]
thanks for sharing this guy
well i noticed a lot of new faces this
evening
and i'm so glad you all came and i want
you to know
that this is a safe place to share
so if you want to tell us your story
there'll be no judgment
sure i'll go
hi y'all name's wendell
and i am in fact
a sexual addict i wouldn't know
and what brings you here wendell well
you know my life sexually speaking
is crazy and i just want to find
one single solitary person
to spend the rest of my life with just
one just one
so do you feel like your addiction is
too much to handle
right now duh i mean it's been crazy
y'all
with me the nastier the better
i'm a dirty dog try everything
all the fixings tantric
much like sting all the bells and
whistles you name it
i've dunced it and
when would you say you hit rock bottom
wendell
when it got slippery outside my shower
on the floor outside my shower
oh i hit rock bottom
sexually
i was probably last night last night do
you think that you could tell us what
happened
wendell yeah let's see uh
it's just like any other night i had
ordered a large pie
pepperoni pineapple cheesy crust
cheesy bread on the side
i cut to 30 min
later pizza parlor sent over a delicious
lady delivery person
tan face tan
that's my weakness so i invited her
inside
opened up the box it was hot
devoured the first slice lickety-split
crust first
second slice didn't stand a chance ate
the tip of that [ __ ] first
washed it down with a pop
then i got nasty with the cheesy bread
my heart started pounding
harder than usual cursed lunk cursed
slunk
moved on to the third slice what about
the girl what girl
oh the girl yeah she was there too
i invited her into my boudoir aka the
stabbin
cabin we disrobed one another i touched
her on her genitalia she
touched me on my manitalia and that's
when i hit it
sexually of course upstairs downstairs
all around the town stairs as you do
and uh by then it
was just another night i mean oil
everywhere and sauce
all over me sauce
oh yeah that's my word for
ejaculate anywho
i'm so uh distraught because i feel
vulnerable and i don't know i just
feel like anyone could take advantage of
me right now
er knee one
okay let's see what the blondes have to
say first
well thank you wendell um thank you for
sharing it's actually our time today
hello skymall magazine this is riya
speaking hello
riaz i would like to report an item
which i ordered that arrived
broken wendell sanders mockingbird lane
that's right i am showing the last item
that you've received is the superman bed
with the mattress of solitude
that's the one ordered it from a son for
his birthday but i cannot give it to him
like this
and i'm pretty darn tootin pissed about
it
sorry sir i will start processing your
reorder
right now with you on the line okay i
ain't mad at you
rios it's just the system i know okay
thank you for understanding sir kids eh
huh oh okay well yeah i just got the one
myself
had sex with a woman and everything to
get them
how long is this going what is your
son's name
pretty much stimpy i have boys too i'll
tell you sometimes they can be a real
couple of universes
you're preaching to the choir stimpy
don't you
give me that look you're gonna get it
when your mama comes home
oh man sounds like your wife is [ __ ] on
wheels you got that straight riaz
hot little biscuit though name's claire
body 10
face 10. so pretty much hit that every
night
sexually anyway what's holding up though
one more minute and uh how old is her
son
15. 15. and he still wants a superman
bed
a late bloomer enjoy it while you still
can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
they all do
and the second he starts hooking up with
the girls he'll forget all about that
superman and spiderman stuff
pretty much seems like how it would
happen maybe then he'll stop bothering
me with all those
stupid little facts about how those
characters you just named are clearly
from two distinct and separate universes
sadly some people never move on sad i
got a better word for you pathetic well
i i i wouldn't say
but that's okay hey i caused them locks
i see some reals and i don't
tolerate nerds in fact let me nip this
in the bud real quick
stimp it stimpy get back in here i will
i didn't mean to there you are with your
brown
body and your creepy-ass face no more
sweets for you
cause you're never gonna get laid if you
keep eating sweets
and another thing all these
figurines and toys you got around the
house we're throwing them in the trash
cause they're not real people stimpy
they're not real people
so stop being so lonely stop being's
so lonely
well and this is none of my business of
course
but i was wondering if your son
would like to talk to someone
oh simply just jumped out the window oh
my gosh
oh he killed himself why to do it it
must have been my fault no it wasn't yes
it was i'm gonna call the cops don't you
dare cancel that reorder it's the only
thing i'll have to remember him by
[Music]
there's a light and it shines within the
darkness of the sands of time
the fans of time there's our fight
but the battle to be won is with the man
inside
nothing will keep it from
[Music]
like a dream you can never tell the lies
exactly as it seems
[Music]
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
[Applause]
exactly as it seems
[Music]
is believable
[Music]
[Applause]
how i touch the sky
[Music]
is the power of wings